stanstead dans les cantons de l'est
petite ville de 2800 résidant à cheval
sur la frontière américaine
la bibliothèque municipale est même
devenu un symbole
à l'intérieur une ligne hissé par le
canada des états unis
ces jours-ci bien sûr elle est fermée
tout comme les accès qui mènent à 2001
et nos vermand au poste frontalier de la
rue principale quasi désert depuis trois
mois
randy davis a été un des rares à
traverser mardi après midi
j'ai une entreprise aux états unis et la
double nationalité dit il je peux
seulement aller travailler et revenir ce
sera comme ça au moins jusqu'au 21
juillet en ville quelques résidents
comme ben crimes sont contents du
prolongement de la fermeture il habite à
50 mètres les états unis la situation au
sud lui fait peur se voit et le 21
juillet
continued sort le 21 septembre pour moi
vraiment 70 ans j'aidais des maladies
pour monde c'est au pdg diabétiques pas
pressé il ya aussi ceux qui sont un peu
contrarié mais sans plus moi ce que ça
change sur tout ce que je peux pas les
manger mes soucis
et puis il y a ceux que ça dérange
vraiment comme hélène hamel son amoureux
habite à cinq minutes de chez elle et
pourtant depuis la mi mars
elle ne peut pas être avec lui je t'aime
entrées c'est parce que à chaque mois on
nous annonce un hautement un hautement
on est plusieurs personnes c'est des
familles mixait anglais français et ils
nos enfants vont à l'école là on vient
ils viennent ici alors je dis on est
divisé la pire que jamais été
c'est très dur c'est très dur on passe
beaucoup de temps sur facetime se
regardait par la vidéo des fois des fois
je dessin à la frontière à cinq reprises
elle est allée voir moins que son
conjoint
ils sont restés chacun de leur côté de
la bande internationale
malgré tout deux fois on leur a demandé
de s'en aller les gardiens surtout les
américains ils n'aiment pas ça ça ne
rigole pas autant de l'aco vides et les
commerçants locaux ne la trouve pas
drôle non plus car il quand un père au
moins 40% de ses clients quand la
frontière est fermée téa les locaux du
côté américain qui viennent c'est
vraiment pour les types de produits
congo pour l'ambiance du café bistro
on a les touristes il y en a beaucoup
qui font la route entre boston et
mauriac comme d'autres en affaires ici
elle espère que tout va rouvrir le 22
juillet qu'on aille au moins la deuxième
partie de l'été
et puis que les les peut-être que les
américains ont continué à peu leurs
parts aux hôpitaux garde des sceaux pour
a pris puisque peuvent de tenir le coup
mais j'aurais préféré effectivement il y
aura des pertes empêcher tout ce monde
travaille et ça risque d'avoir des
conséquences bien plus graves que
quelques villes en question
parmi les grands déçus il y a aussi les
milliers de canadiens qui ont une
résidence secondaire aux états unis
marie-claude chayer et caroline khoury
possède ce chalet sur un immense camping
du vermont à 15 minutes des douanes
elles y passent tout leur était depuis
15 ans entourée de près de 300 autres
propriétaires québécois s'est beaucoup
de colère et d'incompréhension je dirais
parce que
on sait pas où on s'en va on soit
confiné ici à montréal ou chez nous dans
le vermont quelle est la différence
c'est pas un facteur de danger pour
propager le virus depuis mars
elle demande sans cesse aux autorités
des deux pays une exception pour se
rendre chez elle son succès qu'est ce
qui va se passer au mode ou en septembre
ça va être la même chose on va être dans
la même situation les frontières vont
rester fermés combien de temps comme ça
elle espère au moins sortir de
l'incertitude comme bien d'autres le
long de la frontière